jelly roll
who I don't really know anything about I
take it that he is a musician he has a
lot of face tattoos he's really
interesting looking guy and he's an
interesting sounding guy uh Jelly Roll
Just testified before Congress
about the drug crisis overtaking the
country he's a former drug dealer
himself and the way that we talk about
that crisis and the way that we talk
about crime
broadly I also understand the Paradox of
my history as a drug dealer standing in
front of this committee but equally I
think that's what makes me perfect to
talk about this I was a part of the
problem I am here now standing as a man
that wants to be a part of the solution
I brought my community down I hurt
people I was the uneducated man in the
kitchen playing chemist with drugs I
knew absolutely nothing about just like
these drug dealers are doing right now
when they're mixing every drug on the
market with fent and all and they're
killing the people we
love
I'll be honest with y'all my desire is
to only get older and only do better and
be better I believed when I sold drugs
genuinely that selling drugs was a
victimless crime I truly believe that
y'all my father always told me what
doesn't get you in the wash will get you
in the rents now I have a 15-year-old
daughter whose mother is a drug addict
every day I get to look in the eyes of a
victim in my household of the effects of
drugs every single day and every single
day I have to wonder if me and my wife
today will be the day that I have to
tell my daughter that her mother became
a part of the national
statistic what doesn't get you in the
wash will get you in the rinse I really
like that line I'm going to have to use
that line I think that's a great
Insight but the best Insight that jelly
roll has there is this term victimless
crime because first he he says you know
actions have consequences what doesn't
get you in the wash it get you in the
rinse today we think that actions don't
have consequences we think that we will
totally be uh immune to The Logical and
natural consequences of our actions
there's there's a great meme that was
going around for a while and the meme
was Me
sewing yeah yeah this is awesome I love
sewing yeah yeah this is I love just
sewing and planting all these little
things and that me reaping ooh yikes how
did this happen yeah I don't want to I
don't want to reap what I sew I just
want to keep doing all the sewing that's
really fun we know it we know this about
ourselves that we try to we do we try to
divorce I mean the clearest example is
in sex stuff we we divorce the end of
sex from the from sex itself but we do
we do it in everything man we do it in
everything now we
just I don't know if it's because of a
failure of long-term planning or because
of of a denial of logic I guess that's
probably what it is because in
logic things have consequences and we
deny logic these days and so we end up
with phrases and this is the key phrase
that jelly Ro used we we end up with
phrases like victimless
crime we people on the right use that
phrase especially the segments of the
right that that want to go squishy on
the social issues they say oh who cares
about a victimless crime do you hear
yourself do you hear that phrase that's
a that's a meaningless phrase because by
definition there can be no such thing as
a victimless crime we'll get to why in a
second right now go to goodranchers.com
use code nolles you know what I had for
dinner last night I come home and Alisa
said I just made a quick little sauce I
said okay so it's just pasta well I
forget what kind of pasta and a nice
little sauce and but it was easy you
know you make it in 10 minutes so she
makes this up whatever I said oh this is
really good sauce what kind of sauce is
that just a little meat sauce just a
quick meat I said I don't know what you
know meat sauce is easy it's just the
cned tomatoes and the this and that so
then it occurred to me the the only
thing that that would have determined
how tasty the sauce was was the meat so
I said well where'd you get this like
the best meat sauce I've had in a long
time he go huh oh I just got the the
good ranchers hamburger and I kind of
just and it was the good ranchers meat
of course it was good ranchers has the
absolute best meat out there their
chicken is unbelievable their beef is
unbelievable they all their stuff
they've got everything and it's the best
in the business and the prices are the
lowest in the business somehow and it
sells itself I don't know how they do it
go to goodranchers.com use code nkw to
enjoy free chicken in 2024 plus an
additional 20 bucks off your first order
change the way you buy meat by switching
to good ranchers subscribe today use
code nolles kwes to claim over 200 bucks
in free chicken and New Year savings
goodranchers.com American Meat delivered
I hate the phrase victimless crime the
libs use it the libs coined it the libs
popularized it of course but now
everyone uses it people on The Right Use
It Libertarians who argue
for the the decriminalization of drugs
or prostitution or all sorts of weird
social stuff they say oh it's a
victimless crime we should stop Pro
there can't there's no such thing as a
victimless crime do you know where that
phrase comes from the phrase comes from
1965 the 1960s when many many bad things
were coined and popularized uh this is
one of them it was coined in an academic
paper by a guy named Edwin Shure and the
title of the paper was crimes without
victims deviant behavior and public
policy and and you know what his
examples are this is what comes after
the colon abortion homosexuality drug
addictions specifically drug addiction
exactly what jelly roll is talking about
says it's a victimless crime oh yeah
tell that to the parent who lost a kid
to drugs tell that to the many many
mothers and fathers in America right now
whose kids are dead because of Fentanyl
and drugs victimless crime not only are
the kids victims the parent the parents
are
victims the brothers the sisters the
whole political Community you kidding me
drugs are a victimless
crime it's one of the greatest examples
of victimization going on in our whole
country right now we have we have a a an
overdose epidemic that is so colossal
that basically everyone I think everyone
that I know knows someone or or knows
someone who knows
someone who has died because of this
what about the other ones forget
homosexuality for a sec that'll be we
talked about that enough on the show
yesterday two days ago abortion is a
victimless crime you murder a little
innocent baby that's a victimless CRI I
don't think so and those are the best
examples they could come up with by the
way crazy because there's no such thing
as a victimless crime because crime is
by definition an
injustice it's an act of violence
against someone can be an act of
violence against your neighbor it can be
an act of violence against the self it
can be an act of violence against Art
nature and God but it's an it's there's
an injustice there there is a victim
there you
can't unless you just deny sin unless
you deny that anything is better than
anything else you know which I guess
some people do they don't really mean it
because they it's obviously nonsensical
the moment someone says there's no such
thing as Sin there's no such thing as
morality man the question I always ask
is oh yeah would you say it's better to
bake a pie for a widow than it is to
kick an orphan in the head and they look
at me they say oh that's a stupid
question and why is it a stupid question
is you have an answer for it the Smart
Ones among them they don't want to
answer but the answer yeah of course
it's better to bake a pie for a widow
than it is to kick an orphan in the head
okay so if some things are better than
other things then there is a moral order
and there's good and there's
bad if you would if you would go so far
as to say it's a crime to kick an orphan
in the
head you you describing that kind of
Injustice in political terms you're
describing you're describing
victimhood of course man what a great
clip that was now hold up you got to
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
nolles YouTube channel now now please
pretty please thank you appreciate that
see you next time